hey guys Ryan right here I'm gonna be
watching the trailer today for one of
the most anticipated television to movie
things adaptations whatever ever
Entourage I did not actually finish this
series not because I didn't like it at
the time they didn't have like Netflix
and since streaming so I would buy the
seasons of Entourage I couldn't afford
it after a while because I am so bad
with my money I was like on season four
but I lost left off so I've been
avoiding because I didn't want it to be
ruined for me but I'm gonna watch it
because a lot of people have been asking
so I'm gonna watch it I really hope the
last episode is not ruined for me it
probably will be I mean come on it takes
place after okay whatever to make you
happy I'm gonna watch this
sadly all good parties must come to an
end
boy you're upset that I gave you a
hundred million dollars here's 15
million over you agreed to not go over
because you said I couldn't direct
unless we agreed like what a girl asks
do you want to bang her hot sister of
course you say no neither of you really
believes you need it done what is he
doing here she's being really fast
this movie's enormous it fails look at
them in flames quicker than Hindenburg
why did you stop taking the anger meds
I didn't it'll working
I'm okay to continue
I last 30 seconds you let me take your
elevate last 60 seconds oh nice
repackage
around here just like drama wants to cut
them out if they try to cut up my
brother that kills the money even if you
sucked as bad as drama coffee stops
okay I got a I got a [ __ ] finish the
goddamn show like I forgot how much I
loved watching this show like just
seeing them all together again it's so
exciting to me I love you just feel like
you hang out with them every episode I'm
hoping that movie has the same vibe I'm
just excited to see them all together
again I love the opening of the trailer
cuz like it's supposed to be a movie
that Vince is starring in but the movie
actually like looked good
it wasn't like how a lot of movies would
do it where the movie kind of like I
remember when he was an Aquaman I was
like a pretty good Aquaman movie
actually and this one looked like it was
a good film to hearing that Vince is
like moved on to direction I don't know
if he moved on to direction in the show
but to do directing is like that's
that's cool and see them take a
character to that point is neat cause
I'm like a lot of actors actually do
that and just that scene where it's like
you see the gang and Ari and like that
interaction sites it's all there again
it's all it's all there you know it's
got all the [ __ ] that people [ __ ]
love you know bagging on turtle and and
hot [ __ ] and nice cars you know it's
it's a real dude show it's cool to see
them just honoring what it was it's not
like Sex in the City - I watch most of
Sex in the City as well and whenever an
actor loses weight I'm excited for that
so turtle me and him being skinny is a
fresh take on this there's like a lot of
celebrity cameos they actually showed in
the trailer we saw Billy Bob Thornton we
saw hailey Joel Osment who's you know
like where the [ __ ] semen and he got fat
I'm losing weight right now hailey Joel
Osment
I see dead people more like I see fat
people lose some weight and Mark
Wahlberg of course you know the producer
and based on his life of course having
him in it is exciting man and like he
does you know fairly good amount of
comedy now so it's cool to see him you
know honoring this film and being in it
so yeah I am I'm so there and I'm gonna
finish this show as soon as possible
thank you guys for forcing me to watch
this trailer
I did not ruin the last episode for me
if you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects where we
sort of have an entourage of you know
like I have an entourage Jerry
Alyssa Dan Sally Oh baby I'm part of
your entourage meaning we're all part of
your entourage
it's like multi-level marketing aren't
enough shoutouts again let's shout some
[ __ ] out Anthony argot sometimes when
I'm lonely I touch myself to your videos
also what did you get for Christmas and
when are you posting your sex tape
Anthony Eric got that's kind of gross to
me because my brother's name is Anthony
so to hear that you're touching yourself
makes me think my brother is I can't
even finish that sentence what did I get
for Christmas
I can tell you what I didn't get I
didn't get a male stripper like I asked
for I wanted a male stripper a black
male stripper to prove I'm not racist
and homophobic and when are you posting
your sex tape I never have sex with my
girlfriend she doesn't allow me
brendensen yard hey bro you are awesome
and funny I'm willing to fight Justin
Bieber and One Direction in death match
at the same time to get a shout out keep
up the good work
I'm awesome and funny yeah I am awesome
and funny who willing to fight Justin
Bieber in one direction I think most
people above the age of 13 are willing
to do that I believe the majority of the
world would prefer it if they just
didn't exist so you're not anything
special right now Brendon but yeah you
can get a shout-out thanks for saying I
should keep the good work because I do
think I put in a lot of hard work I mean
it's not easy to sit here and watch
trailers it's yeah Mike I really earned
my way
I cannot be more [ __ ]
Oh Brendon sin yard I committed this sin
in this yard
this is I own the yard Josiah Yancey any
chances I could get a shout out thanks
well um the rules to getting a shout out
are you have to say something
interesting you just asked a question
so should I show you out is that fair to
do Yancey Yancey your last name is
Yancey do you that's just I don't think
it means anything it sounds like a mean
thing to say to someone it sounds like a
homosexual insult
look at that Yancey over there meaning
you're homophobic wait no you're called
Nancy meaning you're gay but not in a
derogatory way I don't know where to go
with this you know why because you
didn't say [ __ ] for me to work off of
you [ __ ]